so don when we go through the process of
hiring so
you have a recruiting firm staffing
company you work with maybe your hr
lady or whoever the gentleman that's
working hr whoever it is that's running
vp of operations i'm looking for 3d
employees we're need somebody that's
doing x
y z what's the next step take us from
there
well we've used all of those we've used
head hunters we've used recruiting
outfits we've just put out on social
media
you know depending on the position and
how hard it is it would be to find that
person
uh from there we actually uh ask for a
video interview we give them a series of
questions
they send us a video that's the first
thing that we look at because you can
just tell a lot by somebody's confidence
when they're looking in the camera
uh and then we we put them through a
series of of questions that that ask
you know what would you do in this
situation if this came up and we're
looking for creativity
uh we're looking for follow-through
we're looking for excellence
you know patrick you know as well as i
do if you hire the wrong person it's
going to cost you an enormous amount of
of opportunity cost you know it's one
thing and and
the other thing is we hire slow and we
fire quick
so within three or four months if we
made a bad decision we let that person
know hey we don't think you're a fit for
this organization
we we think you're great you're gonna do
well somewhere else
we misjudged it and i think we're about
70 30. we get it right about 70
of the time the reality is you just
can't know until somebody gets into the
seat
and the other thing that we'll do
patrick is we're very gracious and
in one sense if you're not working out
in this position we will actually try to
find
some other way in the company for you to
make us money
and that's a challenge on the leadership
to say you know this person isn't good
at this
but let's ask ourselves is there
something we can do with this person
some sort of job description that we
would
we could give them that would allow them
to make the company money and be a great
investment
and you know a quarter of the time or
more we actually find an opportunity for
them
but that's a paradigm shift that leaders
need to need to understand
that you always want to be creative how
else could we make money how else could
we grow this
company and is with this person does
this person have an opportunity
to do something here that would be
really amazing you know we discovered
one of our guys that they were an
academic they were just very they were
just very good at interacting with
universities so we created a whole
program
for them just to get our curriculum
taught inside the university system
and that has been lucrative for us that
position didn't exist
as a as a business strategy it came to
us because we were looking at the skill
set
of one of our team members that makes
sense so going back to step number one
is video interview they send it to you
number two a series of questions are
there a lot of open-ended questions or
the multiple choice
is it i have to write a few sentences to
explain how it would handle a situation
what is it like
it's all written tests because if
we want them to write paragraphs uh and
the reason for that is we're looking for
the rare individual who can write
if you can these days patrick if you
know you know this
if you can write you are deadly and
what's amazing is we're all texting all
the time on our cell phones we right now
more than we've ever written before
we're sending emails but so few people
can actually do it
well we're a company that is known for
communicating very clearly can you
imagine if we send an
email that is not clear that's confusing
uh you know we can't have that happen so
that is another thing i didn't bring up
you have to pass the writing test
or you can't work here
so that's a must that's not even no
matter how much you like them if i can't
pass the writing test it's a no-go
no not at all yeah how long is the
writing test we're like we're like a
band if you can't sing or play an
instrument you can't be in the band that
makes sense
at least you know you know what you
can't fail and so
how long is the writing test oh it's not
very long you know in a couple pages
whether or not somebody can
can be concise yeah we will also ask
them to do their job
so we just hired a podcast uh producer
out of chicago
and we actually sent them hours and
hours of interviews with me interviewing
people
and just said hey take this and turn
this into a podcast episode
that you think is entertaining and they
actually had to turn in a finished
product before we hired them
so that's a form of a test you know if
you don't know if they can do it here's
a test for you see how you do it and it
will come back and
if you surprise us you're in if you
don't this may not be for you
that's right and we're looking for rock
stars we're looking for
we're just looking for absolute rock
stars and that's a a
saying that goes around my company rock
stars only i mean
absolute the best that we can possibly
get
[Music]
you